cette semaine rendent au pays vous
propose une boucle facile au dimitile le
tour de la ravine de l'arg hamas par les
sentiers le doyen et des trophées
mondiaux
rendez-vous à l'antre-2 direction l'est
du massif un premier départ est possible
ici mais en continuant un peu plus haut
se trouve un parking aménagé devant le
départ principal du sentier
la randonnée commence sur le sentier des
trophées mondiaux en direction plein
nord de l'argana ce le nom que l'on
donnait aux surfaces planes sur lesquels
on faisait sécher le café au soleil
c'est aussi le nom de la ravine dont on
fait le tour
le sentier en balcon offre de beaux
points de vue sur la cote mais aussi sur
le haut de la planèze en contrebas de
cette zone qui a été fortement exploitée
la rabine est un îlot de verdure en
partie préservée qui permet d'observer
quelques pauses individus d'espèces
indigènes
comme ce grand nate se boit de jolis
coeurs ce bois dur ou sept espèces plus
rares ici menacé par le galabert le bois
d'ortie le cortège floristique dans les
ravines est vraiment intéressant
lorsqu'il est composée en majorité des
espèces indigènes car c'est des milieux
qui n'ont pas été touchés par
l'agriculture et par les défrichements
tandis que quand on monte sur la planète
du dimitile là haut comme c'est un
endroit qui est extrêmement peuplées et
exploité on va se retrouver qu'un
cortège très exotique avec une
prédominance de l'acacia la raison pour
laquelle la visitation encore en bon
état c'est tout simplement à cause du
relief ce sont des endroits où les
quatre moins possible de cultiver ou
quoi que ce soit la deuxième raison
c'est que les ravines ce son domaine
public de l'état donc elle n'appartenait
à personne on retrouve les mêmes la même
configuration dans à peu près toutes les
ravines et c'est bien pour ça que le
parc national comprend quasi une grande
grande partie des ravines souvent on
allait les planèze qui sont hors coeur
de parc qui sont adaptés
exploité et caetera et puis ensuite le
coeur de parc démarre dans les ravines
et dans les remparts
il a ravi le dollar gamas fait partie
des cinq ravines qui ont été intégrés au
coeur de parc dans cette partie est du
dimitile avec la ravine tabac la ravine
la cape la ravine pied de cannes et
enfin la plus à l'est la ravine mal au
ventre
tout un réseau de sentiers de piste
permet aussi d'en faire le tour mais les
pistes n'étant pas ouverte à la
circulation
les boucles comme les marches d'accès
sont plus longue
celle que nous réalisons autour de cette
première ravine reste donc la plus
accessible du massif et la plus facile
ben ouais
sur l'autre versant une remontée facile
en direction de l'arg hamas nous fait
traverser un petit bras de ravine
complètement envahi on a un affluent de
la rabine argue hamas on peut voir
énormément de l'ong osé de raisin marron
donc c'est
les ravines sont des endroits qui sont
extrêmement riches effectivement mais
également extrêmement vague et on peut
avoir une propagation des espèces
exotiques via les radis parce que c'est
un milieu qui est constamment perturbée
par l'eau parler et donc la végétation
est arrachée et ça laisse la place pour
les espèces exotiques pour s'installer
et il ya un deuxième élément qui rentre
en compte c'est que les ravines sont un
endroit où il va y avoir un puits de
lumière il ya moins de couvert végétal
le fond de la ravine et donc ça ça
permet à vos espèces exotiques qui en
général aiment la lumière à s'installer
à cet endroit tant qu on enlèvera pas le
couvert végétal sur sur un rempart de
rabin ça restera en l'état en bon état
arrivé à l'argana ce c'est
l'intersection avec plusieurs sentiers
qui permettent de continuer vers le haut
du massif ou plus à l'est vers les
autres radine celui que nous empruntons
c'est le sentit le doyen qui redescend
plein sud sur l'autre versant de la
ravine
une ambiance différente en crète parmi
les acacias et les fougères et qui offre
encore de beaux points de vue sur le sud
et la planèze du tampon
une descente plus prononcée permet de
rejoindre le fond de la ravine
va
en
face il faudra fournir un petit effort
pour gravir les 150 m de dénivelé
restant pour rejoindre les citernes et
notre point de départ
pour moi c'est une randonnée qui est
très intéressante lorsqu'on passe par
exemple une journée ou un week-end à
l'antre-2 qu'on a envie de faire un
petit tour si on part tôt le matin ça
prend une demi journée donc c'est une
jolie ballade qui a
à destination de gens qui marchent pas
trop quoi l'intérêt ce que l'on fait pas
d'aller retour on fait une petite boucle
d'environ 2 3 heures donc ça se fait
bien dans la matinée sur une petite
boucle comme ça qu'a l'air de rien on se
retrouve quand même avoir des points de
vue assez intéressant on sait -
panoramic que le zèbre ou la grande du
mans mais par rapport à l'effort à
fournir tout à fait correct ce que
j'aime moins c'est qu'on est on est
quand même environné de
d'espèces envahissantes un peu tout le
long
voilà on sait pas si on est pas immergé
dans de la belle forêt quand même quoi
il ya des jolies point de vue il ya une
ambiance forestière mais on n'est pas on
n'est pas dans des milieux
vraiment
d'exception